we wrote a song parody to these eyes i
have it right here what do you think you
think it's it's the gary's teeth it's
about gary's teeth
we always write song parodies to gary's
teeth every time a a big artist comes in
these you want to give it a shot i'll
give it a try all right give it a try
see how it's
because you see it it's about time we
updated the lyrics to your to your great
hit
[Music]
this is my first try now all right give
it a shot see what you think
these guns
are green and black and smell
like a sewage those teeth
[Music]
stink like you ate a
cow manure
[Music]
you look dumb and goofy
[Applause]
[Music]
you big baby
it must be hard when you chewy
with those choppers those choppers
how am i doing you're doing great
well i'll continue on then keep going
here we go these teeth
those lips
[Music]
look like they were made
from two tires and that tongue
that's the tongue snacks and licks so
much
you get tired
[Music]
you've got some food from last week yeah
on your choppers your droppers
those teeth are putrid
those teeth goodbye through gay rock
they must drag when you walk and the
odor is a real funky
those teeth are monstrous
those teeth are bigger than a sink and
yeah they really stink and you look like
a monkey
wow what can i say it's my first try but
what do you mean
brilliant that's the way you should have
written it originally
you